en décembre la production c'est là que
la magie s'opère la pme poche et fils a
connu le succès avec ses t-shirts aux
poches coloris
il y a un nom le fondateur a décidé de
suspendre sa production les vendredis
ces employés travaillent 32 heures mais
conservent leur plein salaire on
parvient à faire autant en moins de
temps mais surtout il trouve une
solution à la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
perdu de productivité puis d'être
capable d'offrir quelque chose qui
retient des talents pic y en a charles
david a d'abord craint que la réduction
des heures impose une cadence infernale
la première stratégistes et regarder les
tâches qui ont fait tous les jours sont
littéralement avec un gage d'efficacité
la productivité a pris un nouvel élan le
plus dur feeling c'est comment je vais
faire sinon j'ai eu un mot pour tout
parce que maintenant c'est un cri dans
ma ville avec quatre jours ce même plus
ce que je vois avec la nouvelle
génération c'est qu'il négocie plus
vraiment sur les salaires en fait
beaucoup beaucoup négocié sur les
horaires selon cet expert la semaine de
quatre jours permet aussi aux
entreprises d'économiser à long terme
dans certaines entreprises qui ont un
remplacement d'employés de 30 à 40 % par
an ça veut dire qu'il faut recruter des
gens il faut former des gens chaque
année vous perdez des gens qui avaient
beaucoup de connaissances qui était
importante à l'entreprise je l'envoyais
l'invitation à la candidose le chef de
la technologie chez la jeune pousse
expédie box qui conçoit des casiers
sécurisé pour la livraison de colis à
une ans dans son jeu pour élargir sa
petite équipe 32 heures en quatre jours
c'est ce qui a convaincu nicolas lui
pied d'accepter un emploi un peu moins
payant pour ne pas être prisonnier de
son horaire
qu'est-ce que je sacrifie pas en ce
moment
ma santé mentale ma santé physique pu
tant que je pense avec mes enfants
qu'ils soient que pour certains
employeurs savent avec leurs méthodes
pour se distinguer mais réduire de 20%
les heures travaillées permet-il de
gagner une productivité équivalente dans
tous les secteurs économiques qui semble
que la semaine
de quatre jours soit un petit peu plus
adéquat pour les travailleurs du savoir
que les travailleurs des usines le fait
de ne pas opérer une journée complète
salle une conséquence négative sur la
quantité de production possible chez
expédie box les opérateurs ont une tâche
manuelle et travaille plutôt 40 heures
en quatre jours l'apport qui est
nécessaire à la réflexion la créativité
est moins important ces travailleurs
sont un peu plus répétitif le gain du 32
heures et on sent un peu moins ici aussi
les employés sur la chaîne de production
obtient un salaire horaire et
choisissent pour la plupart de
travailler de plus longues heures malgré
des horaires à deux vitesses
l'expérience est séduisante je peux
vraiment contents qu'on leur fait plus
je me demande ce qu'on le prophète le
sto après les pme autour des grandes
entreprises d'éprouver le modèle ici
jean philippe use radio canada montréal